mais il a ressemble à beaucoup de jeunes
filles de son âge mais si sur la toile
elle est hyper active dont la vraie vie
milla est presque invisible
elle est protégée 24 heures sur 24 jour
et nuit par plusieurs officiers de
sécurité
milla a déménagé et vit désormais seul
dans un petit appartement dont l'adresse
est tenue secrète
elle n'est plus scolarisé elle prépare
son bac par correspondance avec le cned
milla elle se concentre sur ses passions
le maquillage d'effets spéciaux et
l'écriture elle s'apprête d'ailleurs à
publier un livre sur son histoire
intitulée je suis le prix de votre
liberté et la faute dernière minute le
procès a été renvoyé au 21 juin après
l'examen de questions de procédure
merci juan branco d'abord la date là
merci d'être avec nous et où vous êtes
l'avocat de l'un des accusés et jean
messia bien sûr président de l'institut
apollon toujours alors déjà comment se
déroule le procès écoutez on a déposé
dès ce qu'on appelle des questions
prioritaires de considérer aujourd'hui
enfin je n'ai été posées on en a discuté
quasiment tout l'après midi qui vise à
faire sauter la loi schiappa de 2018 qui
est celle d'hyper metz et ses procédures
en gros la loi schiappa safex même si
vous avez pas receler quelqu'un ça vous
avez fait un seul message sur un sujet
vous pouvez être poursuivi
parce que d'autres personnes ont écrit à
ce sujet et on fait des menaces ce qu'on
fait c'est moi c'est ce qui arrive et
que mes clients il s'est réveillé un
matin
en novembre le 15 novembre 2001 il a vu
que milla était en top tweets qu'elle
avait encore fait une déclaration sur
l'islam extrêmement violente et il a
décidé de il a écrit un message
graveleux sans menace mais un peu d un
peu dégueulasse quoi où il dit en gros
que qu'elle doit pas être satisfaite
dans sa vie sexuelle on est terme un peu
plus crue et et qu' il faudrait corriger
ça et il s'est retrouvé et c'est tout
voyez si s'exprimer là comme ça pourquoi
parce que en fait miami là entre temps
elle avait fait tous les médias elle
était à quotidien elle était avec avec
le gouvernement avec ses confrères et
tout ça enfin avec part d'un de mes
confrères ils ont fait monter la sauce
pour en faire une affaire énorme
nationale moi je trouve ça moi je trouve
ça vraiment sale l'idée d'
instrumentaliser une adolescente qui
évidemment à son âge elle fait elle fait
des déclarations qu'elle peut comprendre
pas comprendre qu'elle peut comprendre
la portée pas et en fait il ya des
adultes des gens curieux que kinky
topical pardon qui tout d'un coup mettre
la main dessus
fait et c'est d'en faire un débat qui va
diviser la société qui va accroître les
violences et des tensions et à partie et
moi mon client et cela c'est à ce moment
là c'est pas au début et je vous dis
alors de la première déclaration que
cette affaire a été aussi médiatisée
parce que tout le monde a voulu la
récupérer
c'est ça aussi ce qu'elle était aussi
médiatisé donc là dessus je suis assez
d'accord et boussu suis arrêté par les
singles aux gens tout ça a été un
déferlement tout le monde d'avoir un
service d y auriez cette affaire et être
le défenseur et l'avocat du temps on
raconte n'importe quoi sur la faire et
du coup on pousse les gens donc les
français en fait à se prononcer dessus à
être extrêmement virulent et il
m'attendait sur ce combat parce
qu'évidemment on a tous de l'empathie
naturelle m'a pourri our chiquissime
menacée j'en ai assez qu'ils par
ailleurs et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
menaces de mort avait il ya des choses
qui doivent être condamnés c'est évident
alors mais c'est juste
l'instrumentalisation qui me semble
vraiment sale justement regardez ce qu'a
dit l'avocat 2000 à tout à l'heure
et il explique sa nouvelle vie allant
juste un peu pour à vendre avant rappel
des faits 18 janvier 2020 c'est milla
donc une jeune lycéenne de 16 ans qui
publie une vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux
elles y critiquent fortement l'islam et
l'insultent même avec de nombreux mots
très déplacé le coran il n'y a que de la
haine là dedans votre religion c'est de
la merde votre dieu je lui mets un toit
dans le trou du cul voilà ce qu'elle a
dit très vite la vidéo se répand sur les
réseaux sociaux il fait un énorme buzz
certains internautes qui n'acceptent pas
que l'islam soit critiquer et insulter
réagissent très violemment
la jeune fille se fait harceler l
insulter et menacer de mort on la traite
de française de merde de [ __ ] lgbt de
sale chienne on menace de la brûler ou
de l'enterrer vivante vous dire ça va
très très très très loin et le débat
prend de l'ampleur sur les réseaux
sociaux les hashtags je suis mis là
s'oppose au hashtag je ne suis pas mis
là après laffaire est récupéré par de
nombreux politiques comme vous l'avait
dit et de nombreuses personnes et c'est
vrai que là aujourd'hui son avocat riche
alma richard malka s'est s'est exprimé
et il nous dit qu'elle reçoit il a reçu
plus de cent mille messages de menaces
de morts par jour regarde écoute et
aujourd'hui se défend une jeune fille de
18 ans
qui depuis 18 mois a reçu ce plus de
cent mille messages haineux et de
menaces de mort lui promettant de se
faire découper ligoté écartelée alors
moi je me fais pas moi je m'en remets
pas tous les jours et je ne me remets
pas non plus du fait que l'école notre
système éducatif lui ai dit qu'elle ne
pouvait pas la protéger et que ce soit
elle qui ait été écartée je ne me remets
pas que ce soit la seule jeune fille de
ce pays pour la première fois de notre
histoire qui doivent être protégés 24
heures sur 24 par des policiers que
c'est insupportable alors et donc vous
êtes trop nombreux qu un des avocats de
l'un des accusés de ce qu'on appelle les
cyber harceleur et le profil de ses
harceleurs 2001 sont des gens sans
casier judiciaire de toutes origines
vraiment voilà regard des personnalités
lambda ils ont entre 18 et 30 ans il ya
parmi ces personnes
jeune femme trois jeunes filles et dix
hommes il ya des cuisiniers il ya des
étudiants tout à l'heure on a même vu
l'avocat d'un d'un surveillant d'un
lycée agricole qui comparaît aujourd'hui
ils ont indiqué en fait qu'il ne pensait
pas que ça allait prendre une telle
ampleur de tels recchi à les avoir de
telles répercussions
elles encourent des peines et qui sont
qui peuvent être assez lourd dans ces
deux ans de prison 30 mille euros
damende pour le harcèlement en ligne et
pour les menaces de mort ça c'est trois
ans de prison et 45000 euros d'amendé
alors justement on vous pose la question
faut-il emprisonner les cyber harceleur
jambes et saoud et oui bien entendu les
emprisonner ça dépend de la gravité des
faits parce que le cyberharcèlement ça
peut aller à l'âme de la menace de mort
réitérées au simple fait que de recevoir
un message d'insulté bon moi
personnellement parlons je reçois des
menaces de mort réitérées je porte
plainte et j'attends bien que si la même
personne ne menace de mort à plusieurs
reprises menaces de mort mes enfants et
bien la justice peut pas rester les bras
croisés mais je voulais rebondir ce que
vous disiez mettriez un instant c'est
que en fait on est dans une
configuration un peu bizarre et est ce
que la défense que vous avez exciper
tout à l'heure mais un peu surprise donc
en gros à partir du moment où il ya des
effets de groupe ça déresponsabilise en
quelque sorte les individus qui y
participent
on a exactement la même logique qui joue
lorsque vous avez une horde de personnes
qui s'attaque à une voiture de flics et
qui jettent des cocktail molotov et de
les brûler comme on n'a pas les preuves
en fait de qui a fait quoi mais qu'on a
juste la preuve du groupe ont dit bah
finalement les mêmes avocats disent
banon les individus ils sont pas
identifiés comme ayant participé vous
savez la dernière fois que ce genre de
logique a été à peu près faire des
phrases courtes la dernière fois que les
cette logique qui a été adoptée c'est au
moment des grands totalitarismes du 20e
siècle et en particulier du fascisme et
du nazisme ou effectivement on a des
déresponsabilisez les individus en
disant on recevait des ordres on
appartenait à un système alors c'est pas
exactement la même chose aujourd'hui
mais moi ça me choque pas je pense que
j'ai compris d'abord moi je me bats pour
éviter à des personnes d'aller en prison
pas l' inverse donc je suis pas dans une
logique répressive à ce stade c'est à
présent chose
la deuxième justement le problème de la
loi de chapelle
c'est quand elle permet de faire arrêter
des personnes les mettre en prison y
compris si elles sont pas coordonnées ou
qu'elle n'avait pas l'intention d'agir
ensemble c'est ça qui est grave c'est là
où il ya une différence qui est
importante en l'occurrence où mon client
il s'est juste prononcer sur une affaire
hyper médiatique
il a fait un commentaire hockey qui
était pas intelligent très bien mais il
a été arrêté chez lui à 6 heures du
matin mise en garde à vue enfin menotté
à lisieux sortie de son de chez lui
amener à paris pendant 48 heures pour
être mises en garde à vue il a un
contrôle judiciaire avec un portage le
domicile de ses parents a été
perquisitionnée vous savez à quel point
ça peut être violent une perquisition
imaginez-vous pour la mère de d'un gamin
qui n'avait jamais rien fait aucun
antécédent judiciaire etc
je vois déjà la récupération venir sur
cette affaire je tiens à préciser qu'il
est catholique en plus donc il n'y a
même pas un mot sur justification aussi
on peut s'interroger sur l'échantillon
parce que quand vous avez vous avez
senti le danger de mort
j'en vienne pas nous expliquer parce
qu'on fait là évidemment 99% des gens
qui ont menacé qu'ils sont qui se sont
tissés les unions en fait là où cette
affaire est intéressant c'est que
justement ce qu'on voit avec le
gouvernement est complètement impuissant
sur cette affaire visiblement ils savent
pas comment gérer ce truc de façon
générale sur les questions religieuses
et compagnie on sent que c'est simple
c'est un point difficile pour eux ils
savent pas comment prendre position et
donc du coup ils envoient les policiers
en fait faire des arrestations un peu
arbitraire dans le pays on prend de
quelques-uns comme ça donc il tombe par
exemple sur mon client qui n'a rien à
faire là vraiment je vous assure et du
coup et en fait ils en font un énorme
procès médiatique en jouant justement de
cette instrumentalisation pour donner
l'impression qu'ils traitent le problème
sérieusement mois la vidéo initial qui a
généré tout ce torrent de haine m'a
profondément choqué géré de la même
façon bon moi je suis chrétien
pratiquant quand frau mais sur france
inter chante jésus avait aussi sa majo
sur un capot s'il salue à coke
mais en fait le on a le droit de ne
choquer en france et c'est pas pour ça
que ça justifie que j'envoie à une fille
qui me choque one chanteur qui me choque
je vais à gorges et merci l'enterrer
vivant c'est tout ce que je dis je
comprends que la vidéo ait choqué des
gens
maintenant la question à se poser c'est
pourquoi une seule religion en france
lorsqu'elle est critique et suscite ce
genre d'auto rang parce que le sionisme
a été nommé le colonialisme a été
si vous n'en savez que j'attendais d'eux
a fait escale jo une vidéo concernant
une autre religion peut-être ses vues
sur france inter qu d'une radio publique
non mais attendez c'est un parolier qui
a été applaudi sur une radio publique
et il n'a jamais fait ça dépend
c'est seulement arrondi m'a choqué qu
est ce qu on en savait que la main reçu
des menaces
mais moi je suis persuadé qu'ils ont
leurs chances que si on en a reçus il
l'aurait fait état bon moi je vous dis
on a pu se dire si pour ma part ce sont
1000 dans les jeux vous dites moi je
pense que l'on a reçue et la même partie
est ce parce que le ça n'avait rien à
voir
c'était une personne qui faisait une
parodie alors il parodie mais là n'est
même pas mais bon les grêlés quel est le
point commun entre l'île à eric zemmour
zineb el rhazoui etc enfin il y en
action sa maman à toi c'est quoi le
point commun je voulais de l'isère ils
sont tous sous protection policière
d'accord ils sont menacés en permanence
24 24 est obligé l'imam chalghoumi même
chose parce que lui prône a fait savoir
que vous voulez moi le problème
quel que soit le sujet vous déroulez
toujours la même chose la wii mais
demain je vais parler de deux rodger
federer vous allez sortir oui non mais
là le problème on prend les mois la
vidéo concert je trouve que là sa
démonstration justement on conte et on
est en train de tomber dans le piège qui
nous est tendu c'est à dire on utilise
une jeune femme qui a eu des propos qui
sont ridicules déplacer et ça crée une
réaction sociale qui en pour une partie
d'entre elles extrêmement déplacée est
grave très bien et à partir de là en
fait à partir de cette jeune fille qui
n'aurait jamais dû sortir de l'anonymat
qu'ils auraient dû être protégé et
points et s'assurer que les choses se
calment est on en a fait une affaire
nationale où on commence à avoir des
débats atroces sur la question
religieuse et la question de qui est
coupable de lui alors même mais ça
profite à quelqu'un c'est en fait il ya
des gens qui rentrent ali cette affaire
mais bien qu'on puisse il fait monter
dans les médias
j'ai joué aujourd'hui l'entente les
faits et je suis fini là dessus et je
suis là mais juste mancini a dit ce qui
fait que mon client encore une fois ce
qui est catholique donc ça n'a rien à
voir avec une question de religion mais
bien sur steam sont en garde à vue
perquisitionné
mais pendant 48 h musée est fermé et
aujourd'hui au tribunal et recoins
c'était quoi les mois ce qui l'a mis en
colère il a dit dorilas il a dit et jugé
au lion des panneaux fleurissent est
important mais c'est important de vous
dire il a il a dit qu'elle avait une
sexualité qui n'étaient pas des bananes
et y arriver non il n'y a pas de menace
d'ailleurs il n'est pas poursuivi pour
menaces ne pas poursuivre mais pour
mieux ses efforts pour que l'échantillon
et cette année je prends la parole comme
ensemble doit être représentatif en dit
bien sûr que c'est justement dans le
film n'est en rien représentatif
décembre en fait jean messer en plus il
dit exactement ce que la plupart des
gens disent ici et il veut quand même ce
mec contre nous et ambitionnant
jean-médecin salaires ce qui vous
devriez dénoncé l'impuissance de ce
gouvernement par rapport au terrorisme
par rapport à la laïcité
non merci le fait qu'ils utilisent
utilisent ce genre d'affaires qu'ils
utilisent ce genre d'affaires reste leur
appui science mais c'est ça c'est un
truc que vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'instrumentalisation mais qui a
effectivement dénoncer cette affaire
parce que je vais vous dire et la gauche
l'extrême gauche la france est soumise
la grosse entier la france est soumise
le parti socialiste ou de la politique
mais aussi au fur et associés à la fois
qu'il aurait été aux abonnés absents
mais genre que celles en connaissant tu
n'écoutes stoppait lance en rigolant
il ya une règle ici quand je parle tu te
techno et c'est la règle pareil pour
tout le monde mais sinon tu ne reviens
plus mais je te dis que tu reviens plus
gênant mais seuls sont retour ce tu n'es
pas que cela comprend que l'amérique se
bat comme toi et toi tu braques ou tu
veux savoir l écoute mais non c'est bien
tu ne m'énerve je vais tenir paraissent
toujours j'espère va vraiment me le dit
non mais
évidemment évidemment je suis contre les
harcèlements je suis contre le sida
également en revanche dans le cas de
millas je pense qu'il faut arrêter
désolé mais de victimiser cette fille
qui passe son temps à cracher sur toute
une communauté milla mais ce n'est pas
une raison toujours mais on en a fait un
symbole du cyberharcèlement faut dire
que aussi plein de jeunes qui se font
harceler et si d'actionner gratuitement
à cause de leur physique à cause de leur
religion
à cause de leur sexualité et l pardon
mais je trouve qu'elle passe son temps à
provoquer constamment qu'une religion
c'est de la merde et sans prendre une
communauté après faut pas s'étonner et
je ne cautionne pas le harcèlement
district de la première fois mais non
mais je suis désolé menacé de mort est
ce que tu dis ça donc j'ai même
troisième nom met d'accord mais très
bien donc géré les langues diront s'il
ya des gens qui assurent harceler grâce
à kaka c'est de la provocation alors à
ce moment là tu charries nobel juste et
charlie aussi avait eu des menaces
ça non mais à la raison géraldine nature
quand on parle de miley faut savoir que
même en tant que simple chroniqueur
s'est risqué à dire combien sur dungey
box et on peut avoir très bien ce soir
moi j'ai eu hier par exemple sale [ __ ]
crève bon voilà donc ces espaces encore
m ça je suis pas d'accord avec vous je
cas pas de raison de banaliser les
menaces de banaliser des insultes je
veux banaliser par exemple les adresses
personnelles
bien sûr comme le monsieur de ses écrits
contre la mort on a vu par exemple
l'adresse quand j'allais parler d'un
problème le problème des mesnel de
l'adresse de l'école de son enfant
trouve qu'il ya pas de raison et je
trouve que c'est bien qu'ils les
sanctions voilà et donc voilà donc moi
je trouve que dès son coeur mais après
mon effectivement la prison non alors
vous vous dites oui gilles verdez oui je
dis oui réceptionnés oui mais je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que le cyber
harcèlement
le cyber le cyberharcèlement ça tue
c'est ça peut tuer des gens donc c'est
un procès exemplaire aussi vos clients
et risquent de payer pour cette nouvelle
loi parce que le gouvernement veut
mettre la vie des gens si elle pourrait
être votre fils vous aimez pas et la
vidéo et laissez moi juste terminé de 6
me avec la limite ce sinistré
ceci dit moi j'écris je sais ce terme
est minoritaire
je ne suis pas mis là parce que j'estime
que milla est instrumentalisé que milla
devrais je pense faire un peu silence se
protéger elle-même elle sort un livre là
je ne comprends pas pourquoi elle ne
fait pas attention à elle alors
attention il faut sur liberté
d'expression il faut surtout ni par son
contraire les libère
laissez moi ben on me dit j'ai appris
que je m'appelle fait tiquer céline mais
laissez moi finir via les gars la
liberté d'expression pour milla qui n'a
pas franchi les limites de la légalité
mais je trouve que c'est mais où elle
sort un livre elle s'expose trop je
pense que mon frère si pour elle je
pense qu'il faudrait la protégera
qu'après après être allé pour de la pole
je fais un petit aubin s'indigner de à
géométrie variable mais milan m'a jamais
sur le plateau ce qu'il a entendu
sauf au téléphone excusez moi c'est
aussi abonné puisque que ce que dit me
l'a alors l'été je ne peu importe ce qu
a dit mais là c'est horrible s'est elle
aussi est demandé d'être condamnée et le
ciel ne nous est pas illégal ce qu'elle
a dit aussi
alors êtes vous arrivée gala oui c'est
vrai mais on peut pas on peut pas la
bonne façon pas dire ça que m'est assez
autorisée en france ces insultes c'est
un sens et la raison sur sa jolie avec
bosch bien sûr ça non mais moi je suis
comme chez comme géraldine effectivement
il ya deux choses
il y as que milla tombent sous le coup
de la loi ou pas elle ne tombe pas
visiblement sur le coup de la loi
et puis il ya est-ce qu'on peut au nom
d'un emportements effectivement parce
qu'on peut être horrible et sam et moi
et moi j'ai été heurté par la vidéo et
bien sûr vraiment aimé ça mais c'est pas
parce qu'on ait été blessée qui berça de
mélo on appelle aux moeurs qu'on appelle
à l' égorger à la violette je pense que
ça aurait été plus malins justement de
lui expliquer les choses à dire c'est
vrai bah oui ça pas été la bonne
pédagogie je suis d'accord c'est que moi
je crois effectivement à la valeur
pédagogique de ce procès pourrait pour
dire attention derrière votre ordinateur
quand vous dites quelque chose que vous
pouvez vous vous croyez que vous êtes le
seul et que ça va être un peut-être
tweet un mail que vous allez recevoir
mais peut-être que la personne voir
recevoir sans idée sans nicolas bird
écoles il y avait un petit tour de
pédiatrie je reviens vers vous moi je
pense qu'il faut prendre conscience des
choses à un moment donné c'est à dire
que c'est pas un espace de liberté qui
permet de dire n'importe quoi à
n'importe qui le harcèlement
effectivement tu dans la rue on le
condamne
pourquoi le condamnerait pas aujourd'hui
quand monsieur vous dit ce n'est pas
votre enfant mais c'est pas une réponse
je veux dire à un moment donné moi si
j'ai mon enfant qui harcèlent avec
quelqu'un ou qui menacent de mort ce que
je tiens à vous exprimer
c'est quand même extrêmement expliqué
qu'il ya des personnes qui ont été
prises dans ce procès qui n'ont rien à y
faire
qui n'ont rien à y faire attention pour
l'instant on ne sait pas s'ils ont rien
à y faire j'ai accès au dossier
bien des choses
est-ce que je parle de ces personnes je
parle de mon client je vous exposer
comme les faits de façon assez détaillé
je parle de nuit au goût du client par
hasard je vais pas je parle de lui et de
lui seul est-ce que je vous explique
c'est que justement un moment donné le
gouvernement devait montrer qu'ils
faisaient quelque chose ils devaient
montrer face à la pression médiatique
social et donc ils sont allés chercher
les gens vous tombez dans son truc
politique est ce que vous trouvez par
exemple normale hier que géraldine ou
d'autres autour de la table se fasse
traiter de plus je passe
c'est le faites pas vous ne faites pas
vous ne jouez pas avec la vie de
quelqu'un juste pour envoyer un message
à une communauté ou à des personnes font
le procès [ __ ] n'a pas pour fonction
d'écraser quelqu'un juste parce qu'il
fallait écraser quelqu'un qu'il fallait
envoyer un signal société qu'on faisait
quelque chose ça ne fonctionne pas comme
ça et ça c'est très important de
signaler qu'il y ait des eu des menaces
effectif qui doivent être condamnés
c'est une chose juste que je suis en
train de vous dire simplement c'est que
dans ce procès spectacle qui a été
montée on a mis des gens qui n'ont rien
à y faire qui n'ont aucune volonté de
participer à un harcèlement contre soi
qui ont commenté en fait d'actualité
parce qu'encore une fois mia a joué ce
jeu du co2 de devenir une figure
publique il faut le dire quand même si
on ne parle pas de la première fois où
elle a juste fait une story et je
voudrais dire une dernière chose parce
que c'est très important pour moi
dès le moment qu'on est en train de
commenter de dire est ce que me lapp a
bien fait ou pas bien fait c'est on est
déjà en train de tomber dans le piège
encore une fois cette fille n'a rien à
faire dans le débat public on ne devrait
pas être en train de s'étriper
mutuellement on devrait sans comprendre
pourquoi est ce qu'on est en train de se
déchirer sur un sujet qui n'aurait
jamais dû être dans l'espace public et
qui ne devrait pas être instrumentalisée
pour envoyer des signaux quoi que ce
soit l'endroit où il ya des gens qui dit
voilà c'est pas une raison pour la
menacer de mort le même si sa vidéo
object il ya des gens qui disent aussi
je vous le dis mais pourquoi la raho
commencé quelques mois après à ré
insulte à insulter encore l'islam à la
était pas si traumatisée que ça alors
voilà donc je vous dise qu'on dit après
voilà oui en fait la location c'est
faut-il emprisonner les cyber harceleur
c'est pas faute il juste les punir ou et
sanctionner ces faut-il les emprisonner
aujourd'hui des gens n'arrêtent pas de
dire qu'il ya plus de place dans les
prisons alors déjà en transe crayon plus
de prison et mettons les gens qui font
vraiment du mal dans la vraie vie je
pense que aujourd'hui encore beaucoup de
personnes qui sont mauvaises à mettre en
prison avant les cybers harceleur qui
envoie un truc parce qu'aujourd'hui tout
jouer aussi bien sa voiture doit saisir
là dessus
aujourd'hui serré sur les réseaux on
aime beaucoup plus facilement on déteste
beaucoup plus facilement tout va plus
vite
ici tout se vend la télé c'est que la
sécurité que c'est pas les réseaux c'est
que des réseaux et le cyber harcèlement
dans son nom s'écrit ces cyber tu dois
tenter mais je vous dis il ya des ja
dénia des jeunes élèves il ya des jeunes
des vieux des collégiens des lycéens qui
vivent des drames
m branco il s'y connaît en
instrumentalisation se rappelle de
griffo et démontage politique en la
matière il n'ya pas pour ça ce soir
rappel et lisa sion c'est vrai mais vous
pensez que l'affairé vous n'a pas été
instrumentalisée contre moi vous pensez
vraiment que j'ai participé à la ferme
bien sûr qu'on peut tenir même c'était
avec sa personne c'est aussi sinon on a
essayé d'intimider on va parvenir la
défense mais vous avez été très
largement impliqué mais visiblement ces
sujets c'est parce que j'ai dit c'est
pour ça que je dis pour faire me mia a
eu tort ce qu'elle a fait c'est affreux
et condamnable évidemment mais c'est
dans le droit français elle avait le
droit de s'exprimer et donc c'est
maintenant que je dois dire les cyber
harceleur bien sûr qu'il faut les
condamner et très fermement
parce que c'est insupportable il ya des
suisses absolument oui bien sûr et tout
est encore notoriété enfin on n'est
jamais regardé et c'est pas parce que
c'est pas parce qu'on est jeune et qu'on
dit des conneries sur le réseau qu'il
faut pas les condamner c'est un superbe
film après benayoun elle avait
exactement là pour faire vite
ils ont été retrouvés les rectorats et
je trouve que c'est très bien et c'est
un très bon signal
géant messieurs il faut y aller je ne
sais rien de lui ah oui c'est vrai ça
pour ça que la séquence était bonne
ces trucs jamais ni au début a dit alors
non évidemment qu'on peut regretter y
compris l'évolution de millas qui
écument man en effet un même
physiquement s'est créé un personnage et
on peut le regretter parce qu'elle est
victime et bourreau
maintenant on oublie qu au tout départ
c'est parce qu'elle avait été agressée
verbalement qu'elle avait commencé à
réagir violemment
donc il faut pas confondre la cause et
la conséquence est effectivement n'ont
de toute façon c'est inexcusable ne
proféré des menaces de mort et tout moi
je suis contre l'emprisonnement
je suis pour qui a suivi sur le casier
judiciaire et qu'ils voient
éventuellement un bracelet électronique
qu'ont certains c'est à dire que le est
énorme
énormément de musulmans condamnent
également les menaces de mort bien sûr
il s'agit pas de dire que d'un côté vous
avez que sanofi stable et l'autre côté
qui les a jamais dit saad hassar mais je
précise je dis qu'il ya énormément de
musulmans qui un peu comme les chrétiens
quand il ya quand il ya des choses
contre eux ou les juifs sont très
choqués 150 justifie pas pour autant les
menaces quant à l'instrumentalisation
je suis désolé quand on dit milla a été
instrumentalisée mais ça choqué personne
lorsque le cas quand on a un quand
julien haut doubs la virée enfin a fait
virer la femme voilée du conseil
régional a choqué de marseul que cette
affaire ait été instrumentalisée de
manière abjecte tout le monde était
d'accord pour or pour en faire une
affaire politique
là évidemment comme ça rentre pas dans
les ollières idéologique du système on
est très en mer des dons qu'on dit pas
d'instrumentalisation
mais non je crois que une affaire comme
ça comme dans l'autre affaire c'est
normal que lorsque il y à une affaire
publique ça soit instrumentalisée que
les uns et les autres de leur alma je
suis dans une démocratie on sait juste
que je défends je défends une personne
un jeune français qui n'a pas de
position sociale particulière favorable
qui se retrouve pris dans une machine à
venir a quand même été arrêté par l'anti
terrorisme renvoyer enfin je veux dire
dans une juste pour faire un exemple
c'est la mauvaise personne qui tombe et
on essaie de le détruire à partir de ça
il risque deux ans de prison pour rien
et je pense que revenir au niveau humain
et revenir aux conséquences que
justement tous ces grands débats
politiques et elles peuvent avoir sur
des gens normaux français qu'à un moment
donné on fait un tweet qui n'aurait
peut-être pas dû fermer qui encore une
fois n'était pas une menace n'était pas
adressée à elles n'ont en fait rien à se
reprocher si ce monde si ce n'est
d'avoir été un peu bête un moment en
commentant à fait d'actualité comment
ces personnes là se retrouve au milieu
de cette machine parce
ça sert les intérêts de tel et tel
qu'ils veulent justement faire alors
leur argent et leur notoriété à partir
de là et c'est juste moi je suis du côté
de cette personne
je défends et j'essaie d'éviter on va
manger des conséquences auraient dû
faire bien qu'à saint pacôme il ya soit
5 2% oui pas ben oui à 62 % non 48% oui
voyez donc il faut des sanctions c'est
vrai que la plupart des gens je crois
que la plupart des jours ils sont un peu
d'accord avec nous ils ont été choqués
par la vidéo là mais évidemment voilà il
ne faut pas aussi non plus menacé de
mort il sur les réseaux sociaux mais je
pense que personne ne défend dans ce
débat et crie fayard ce n'est bien sûr
qu'ils fassent menacé de mort bien sûr
de faire sa vie n'était pas personne et
c'est vrai que le cyber harcèlement là
je suis pas d'accord avec delphine ça
c'est apprendre très très au sérieux et
justement il faut justement malardé
utérine et exemple là dessus parce que
c'est extrêmement grave